sous bonne escorte lors des avocats
d'ousmane sonko s'avance vers les
partisans du principal opposant au
président sénégalais il leur annonce la
libération du député qui vient d'être
placé sous contrôle judiciaire
à peine libéré ousman sonko a pris la
parole lors d'une conférence de presse
le député avait été arrêté le 3 mars
dernier pour trouble à l'ordre public
toujours déterminés il appelle les
sénégalais à poursuivre leur
mobilisation face à un président qu ils
jugent illégitime
nous demandons aux jeunes à la
mobilisation de nos bars kazan
mobilisation exceptionnelle
macky sall est à nouveau vous avez trahi
son serment
ma guitare n'est plus légitime à le
diriger le sénégal nous posons nous on
n'a pas encore fini avec la justice
sénégalaise il était une voix inculpé
pour viol présumée menace de mort sur
une employée de salons de massage
maintenant il me reste une audition au
fond et qui permettra de révéler si oui
ou non il ya eu viol ou menaces de mort
son arrestation la semaine dernière
alors qu'il se rendait au tribunal pour
répondre à une convocation à déclencher
un soulèvement d'une partie de la
population sénégalaise
[Musique]
trois jours d'émeutes et d'affrontements
avec les forces de l'ordre
une protestation qui a donné naissance à
un mouvement celui de la défense de la
démocratie composé d'associations de la
société civile et de partis politiques
d'opposition
ce n'est pas normal c'est de la
dictature et nous nous sommes battus
nous nous sommes battus pour être vite
parce que vraiment la vie coûte cher ici
on n'a pas de travail n'est rien par
rapport à mon enfant est pas moi
mahassine and sweet a bien signé je
préfère encore à z
dans ce climat de défiance sans
précédent le président sénégalais sorti
de son silence hier soir macky sall
assure comprendre la colère de son
peuple
il appelle un retour au calme bien vite
au calme à la sérénité
tous ensemble taisons nos rancoeurs
évitant la logique de l'affrontement qui
mène au pire le chef de l'état
sénégalais a aussi annoncé un allègement
du couvre-feu en vigueur à dakar et à
thiès deux régions particulièrement
touchées par le kobe 19 mais pas de quoi
calmer l'opposition qui lance en appel à
poursuivre les manifestations
le dispositif de sécurité autour du
palais présidentiel a été renforcée